gentlemen so first of all the 2023
Canadian Music Hall of Fame inductees at
the junos like how does it feel to be
able to say that this is you guys
it's actually hard to it's hard to
believe that that's actually a real
thing so to be honest yeah
um
yeah I'm kind of speechless it's it's
amazing for somebody to you know
recognize that we we won't go away maybe
that's perfect but
um
no but it's just something when you
started out we didn't start playing to
to end up with something like that I
mean that's just it's an amazing
to to have bestowed on you so the ads
were incredibly flattered yeah I mean
being among the the ranks of the highest
regarded you know musicians that we have
in our country you just said that this
is not something you guys started off
thinking oh this is what we want to do
but like you said you've been around
long enough what are you how do you keep
moving the goal posts for yourself like
what does success mean to you guys now
versus what it meant when you were first
starting out I think it just means
happiness you know now we are afforded
the luxury of just being able to say
let's do what makes us happy and
that's a wonderful thing because I don't
I don't know that everybody has that I
mean
we made a record
that
we knew
wasn't going to be commercially viable
but we just did it anyway because we
wanted to
um
you got to be pretty brave to just do
that but we we all looked at each
other's mind like like let's just make
this record from a couple of you know
maybe the last record possibly is what
I'm probably referring to and we were
just like let's just make this record
and and not worry about
anything like let's just make it
you know and then and then I was worried
about the fans like that's my thing I'm
always just like I want there to be
something on
our records for everybody you know I
really do so we gotta have the good rock
stuff we got to have the heavy stuff we
got to have some melodic stuff we got to
have some big sing-along stuff you know
when we're singing to the uh
the arena
um and so I always keep that in mind
you know because I want I love those
things I love that
um but yeah it's uh
well yeah in regard to like that's what
we get to do that's I think that's talk
about moving the goal posts sure like
that's what he's talking about is is
like we get to
we get to kind of do what we feel it's
like I don't think we've actually set
the goal post I think that's kind of the
thing is that we just we just moving
forward and making more music and just
trying to you know still entertain
ourselves and entertain the fans in the
same sense and uh and these things are
just
I mean it's a pretty great happenstance
to kind of have happen to you but that's
what I guess those are things that
happen when you're busy working right
that's the success we can still work and
we can still do what we want to do
record stuff how we want to do it and uh
I mean how how great is that you know I
find it interesting when um you know one
of the biggest pieces of advice anyone
gives to to artists entertainers is like
if you want people to love you you just
got to be yourself and you got to be
authentic to what you want but that's I
think easier said than done when you're
especially when you're trying to trying
to make something happen and you want
longevity right yeah and you guys are
just saying like
almost now is the time that you're
saying we can just do what we want we
can just do one is that something that
you
um
is that new or is that uh something that
you've been striving for this entire
time or is that something that when you
first came out you were like this is Who
We Are
it's weird because
I have a little bit of a mindset where
we've made fans with so many different
kinds of music that
I want to I
I do want to keep them all happy
I do
um I think a lot of people would sit
here with a camera pointed at them and
say I just make music for myself well
like obviously we make music for
ourselves but I also I also want
to
keep the people who have loved
the stuff that we've done in the past
happy like I'm not so selfish I'm like
no every record is just for me and if
you like it you like it if you don't I
don't care like that's such a such a
selfish thing for me I'm more like you
know these people who have
driven flown
whatever it might be
to come see us play after falling in
love with certain songs
everywhere in the world
to just write them off and be like I
don't care which song you like I'm just
gonna make the stuff I like you know I
just find that to be a little bit
selfish we have a wonderful platform
where we can just make anything we want
and so it's lovely to be able to do that
and and to keep everybody happy but that
keeps me happy as well because if we
just made the same kind of music
straight across just straight you know I
it would be mundane and a little boring
and and it's really really lovely to be
able to make something really aggressive
and rock heavy and to also be able to do
something melodic that everybody wants
to sing along to and you know and
speaking of aggressive and rock heavy
like San Quentin goes hard like sang
Queen goes hard right right off the job
um can you please tell me the story of
how
being at Guy Fieri's birthday party
turns into San Quentin
uh I just simply met him and sorry I
I was walking around a party at my
buddy's birthday party there must have
been a thousand people there and I just
I bumped into somebody and and uh we
started talking and and I was like what
do you what do you do for a living
he said uh I'm the warden for San
Quentin
and he must have seen the disbelief on
my face because I just I was just like
and he was because he was so young okay
I expected this old hardened figure to
be
and everyone behind it was like
he's I'm like oh you're actually the
warden for San Quentin he's like yeah
and then right there I sort of shut off
and I was like
I'm gonna write I'm going to write a
song I'm Gonna Write a Song how often do
you find yourself meeting someone and
going okay this is a song like this is a
song never never never
that was a a rare moment where I was
just like
I just thought to myself like who gets
to meet the inmates uh the warden for
saying all of the inmates
I think probably it's better if you
probably don't meet him
um but yeah I I was it was I
I I felt the gravity of the situation I
was just like wow you're the warden of
San Quentin and for some reason it had
this weight to it and
that's all I was just like okay I got it
this there's something in here somewhere
most times
someone will say something in passing
and I'll be like that's that's
interesting and then I'll kind of like
you know and I'll jot something down
uh but I've never met someone and then
just decided
this is if this is it yeah
um I Heard a story recently about you
guys when you you bought like a bunch of
SUVs and then just dropped them off and
like forgot where they were and you're
like okay well they're going now we're
we're moving on which sounds to me like
a real rock and roll thing to do what is
it it sounds like that's a fantastic
story I've never sounds like you're
smashing up a couple stories am I I
don't know I lost
I lost an SUV in La once okay
um
I was on a bit of a bender and I
it took me a minute to realize that it
was in the underground parking area of
Soho House
like it took me the whole day to realize
where it was but I hadn't seen it in
three days and I was just kind of like
where's my vehicle it's more like I
walked out and I went to the valet and I
was just like hey I got to get going um
he's like yeah okay he's like yeah your
vehicle's not here
he's like it hasn't been here in
probably three days and I was just like
my vehicle hasn't been here in three
days he's like yeah I know
and I had to sit there and I was like
wait
where is my SUV I'm stopping to lose
your car
so that's that's probably the
is it is it better for you guys to be
able to say like actually here let me
clarify this story or is it cooler to be
like let Legends sort of be Legends for
you guys because a lot of people love
these like rock and roll kind of stories
do you ever feel like yeah we're just
gonna let that one go that makes it
sound really really cool it makes you
sound cool sure
I think the last the less press we do
the cooler the band gets I don't know
there's there is something to be said
for that like the less we talk this
interview is over yeah
um
uh one was I got off an elevator here in
Toronto actually and I saw the singer of
another band as I was getting off the
elevator and he's like hey
dude how are you good to see you and
before I could just say he's like did
you buy an island I go did I buy an
island
he goes yeah everybody's saying that you
bought an island
like
no I did not purchase an island
but I said from right immediately after
that I was like but keep that one going
let that one just like let's let that
let's keep that one going for sure no I
did not purchase an island but uh
um you guys have fans obviously from all
around the world and who are uh singing
back your songs to you when you're on
tour when you're touring now at the
stage of the game what do you
need with you uh I guess to keep
yourselves going versus when you guys
were starting is it like
do you get the same sort of feeling of
excitement going on tour now that you
did some years ago
well
it it's just different that's all it
simply is just different I think
um
he'll look at me the first night of a
tour
can I yeah go ahead and if you don't I
will yeah I'll just I'll just divulge
it's it's fine
and it doesn't matter how much you've
rehearsed or whatever and
he looks at me and he's like
you know you hear the crowd go as soon
as the lights come down
I hear that big scream coming up right
and I look I look at him and he looks at
me and he's like he'll go go pop in here
are you nervous I'm like yeah I got I I
got butterflies for sure he's like I'm
nervous
we've done this a million times we're
gonna be okay and that's just me running
up you know a high level of
but uh yeah I feel the same way too it's
like you just you feel nervous I don't
know what it is that we need uh I I
think I just need we need I need you I
need like us you're having us on stage
it definitely helps like yeah I could
it's sometimes like I just couldn't
imagine doing this
by yourself like having a band with you
on stage is like there's
comfort zone yep yeah yeah pretty much
because it's it's uh
it's kind of I think it's kind of
probably still good that you get a bit
nervous before you go because you wanna
you want you want to present the show
how you want to present the show and you
want people to walk away and have a good
time and you want to sing well that
night and you like you you don't want to
go out and just phone it in
so there's something about walking out
in front of thousands and thousands and
thousands of people where
you never really get totally used to it
no by the third song you calm down a
little bit but it's it's like a it's
like a job that it's you have a really
tough time describing to somebody else
it's like it's so weird like that that
feeling
of just like what are we doing what what
do we what I I don't remember signing up
for this and then you're like the next
thing you know these people like this
here someone's just like and go you know
and then yeah that's you you you you go
three two go go go because I have to go
first I have to walk before him onto the
stage right and he'll go and I'll look
at you all the time I just stand there
staring at him like an idiot and he just
goes he's like
and I just walk out there and he follows
me and then I go like this I point in
the sky I point the crowd wow and then
we start the song and it's like a very
high diving board
you first you go first what's it like I
promise how's the water
[Laughter]
uh yeah like it's weird yeah it's so
weird but like I said it's still it's
still good to I think you get that
feeling when we're gonna do it so yeah
you used to like still like doing it and
it's uh
the people want to keep coming I'm happy
about that that's awesome guys that's
awesome hey thanks so much for the chat
uh great to see you guys thanks for
taking time thanks for taking the time